[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
new head coach of the detroit lions 22
years of nfl experience
11 years as a coach 11 years as a player
dan campbell said to join us by the way
let me remind people
since the trade is not official with
matthew stafford going to the rams jared
goff going to the lions
we cannot refer to jared goff
by name this has got to be a
hypothetical
coach do i have that right so you don't
get in trouble i'd hate for you to get
fined
uh that that would be correct that would
be correct
let dan let me say this first of all i
appreciate you having me on um
i've always thought you've done a hell
of a job but i love the uh
you got one of those voices man and uh
it uh it's pretty special man i so i i
enjoy your show and what you do and
appreciate you having me on if you'd
like for me to record your outgoing
message
on your phone i'd be happy to do that
you know what i'll think about that
i will i actually like that a lot that
would be pretty good all right
uh let's go around the room what we
think coach campbell can
bench one rep um todd i'll start with
you what do you think
coach i think was like 6'5 265 when he
was playing he might still be that
by the looks of him uh fritzi one rep
coach campbell
375 375 mclovin 405
405. seton o'connor
i'm gonna go 350. all right paulie
oh man i'm gonna go four bills even one
rep
i'm gonna go 325. coach uh closest
to uh the hole yeah i i can guarantee i
can do 225
once i promise you that what's the most
what's the most you've done
ever in my life yeah for one rep yeah
uh i would say 425. nice
nice that's all i wanted to talk to you
about coach thanks for coming on and we
wish you guys
enjoyed it one of these softballs that's
great
let's do the hypothetical game what what
do you want
your quarterback what traits are you
looking for in your quarterback
if you happen to get a new one instead
of matthew stafford what traits would
you be looking for
what trades would we be looking for what
traits would we be looking for yeah i
would say that uh you'd love to gotta be
blonde
you'd love the guy to have a one and a
six on his jersey
you'd love for uh no i uh look man
you're looking for a guy who
is a winner uh you're looking for a guy
who is uh
he's competitive uh he's got a quiet
confidence about him
he's uh he's durable um
you know and i kind of said this
yesterday on
talking to somebody else but just
somebody that you know
when he's in the huddle and the other 10
guys are looking at him that they
they really believe in this guy like he
you can look at him and know that he's
got a sense of urgency about him he does
have confidence about him and he can
he can kind of calm the storm and just
kind of keep everybody right in line
um and and let them know that man listen
if you just
this guy'll do his job if i do my job um
and i think that's that's kind of the
guy we're looking for
are the lions set at the quarterbacking
position
um it's a good question
uh that's a good question i would say uh
all options are open
would be the best way to say that i
think that we feel pretty good with
where we're going right now but yet
we're open to everything right now
when did you watch your initial press
conference with the lines like did you
watch it after the fact
no i didn't now i had i had friends that
were sending me
bits and pieces of it but i i have not
watched the entirety of it no
what did you think of your performance
um i mean
i was it was fine i mean i look i i'm
kind of a
look i wear my heart on my sleeve a
little bit it's just kind of who i am
and um it's hard for me to be something
that i'm not
and so that was um i just felt like i
wanted to do something for the city of
detroit
our fans and i wanted our players that
was kind of my first introduction to our
players
if you will and so i i just kind of felt
like that's who i needed to talk to
and then once i get going a little bit
man it just kind of
it goes you know it goes from there and
for everybody that thinks that i don't
know that buying kneecaps is not a
personal foul in the nfl believe me i
know that
so i totally get that
i loved it you were passionate but you
were violent in that press conference
did you hear from mom or i mean did you
hear from anybody
sort of outside that football bubble
that went
man what who are you no well
no i i would say because the people that
i heard from are all people that know me
and they know exactly who i am so to
them i think they it was right in line
with what
they knew i was and uh that's just kind
of me
and and that's that's kind of how i talk
um
you know and look you can't take
everything literally
but yet i just want there to be this i
do want us to have a toughness about us
we're
the league now is changed uh in such a
way
uh for the better but also maybe not
always for the better and
yet there's still this element of man
you got to have you got to be tough you
got to be a tough player it's a tough
man's game
and you know you get bumps and bruises
you don't always feel good and
and so to me it's you know one of the
edges that i think you can still have is
even in today's game is how do you
how do you teach your players to a
overcome adversity but then to
understand that listen man your
your days of being 100 you feel 100
those are gone when you walk in the door
you're 100 as a rookie and after that
you're done
so this whole thought of man i got to
feel perfect no you forget about it man
not if you want to not if you want to be
able to produce
and to have a nice long career in this
league it just doesn't exist the guys
who can say you know what i can
i can beat your ass at 85 of what i
really am those are the
those are the guys you're looking for
but
look as fans we want physicality but the
nfl doesn't want more physicality
how do you knowing who you are
how do you teach what you want to teach
but understand
under the guidelines of the nfl coach
yeah sure and those are that's the key
isn't it
i mean that that's that is the key
that's that's kind of the point i'm
making is like how do we get this
advantage back
uh of this aggressive tough team knowing
where the league has gone and the
standards that have been set
and there again i don't have a problem
with the standards when i get it like
look there's ways to be aggressive and
knock the crap out of somebody without
it leading with your head
man there's different ways to do this
thing you know there's so much
information that's come out so much more
that we know about the game
even when i played and so we're not
going to be out there be a bunch of
renegades that are going to be you know
spearing people and we're getting kicked
out of the game that's not what we're
going to be about but i didn't want
i wants to have some type of edge here
of toughness and it doesn't just mean
this physical toughness i'm talking
about
mental toughness man to where these guys
understand that adversity is just a word
that's all it is and the minute you you
choose that that's all it is is a word
and you get through it so much faster
you go over it you go under you go
through it but you get out on the other
side
unscathed i can't imagine your first
pep talk with that first game like
you're going to be out of your skin
right like are you going to be breaking
stuff and banging stuff
and oh i you know well look it depends
on what's around but no
have you done that before do you break
stuff
no i'm not no i'm not a brick i'm not a
brake guy i
i broke one thing before but i don't
break things all the time that's not who
i am i don't run around hitting stuff
and bring baseball bats and
it's not me i'm just look i'm a
passionate guy that's all
and and i feel like um i feel like i owe
it to people i owe it to my players i
look to my coaches i owe it to anybody
that's around me for them to know
exactly who i am
and i feel like the only way to do that
is for the most part you speak from your
heart
and look i'm going to state the obvious
it gets me in trouble sometimes it just
does but i'm sorry
i it's hard for me not to be it's hard
for me to act like something that i'm
not or say something that's written down
on a piece of paper all the time this is
hard for me to do
and uh you know i'd rather just speak
what's on my mind
do you think you could take vrabel in
the octagon
um that's a great question man listen i
bravo and i we obvi we played against
each other he was a hell of a player man
and uh he's one of those guys he's he's
a freaking
he's a man and uh and so if you're
asking me right now hell no
i couldn't do excuse my language
no but listen brabel's a stud man i got
a lot of respect for brabel
i don't know what that is behind you it
looks like when you put x-rays up there
uh like the light that shines on that
what
yeah that's bothering you well no i
didn't know if that's what that's for
like you could put x-rays up there and
look at them
yeah every once in a while just see how
my body's doing
here and i'll put it up and see what it
looks like but what's the most pain you
ever played in
um oh i
jeez man i i don't know i uh
well i tell you what you know what is
funny as this is like i i guess i ended
up having in my time as an nfl player i
think i had uh
i wanted to say 13 surgeries uh just
from you know now a lot of those were
clean up but some of them were in
ir injuries so i had some i guess what
you call measure injuries but after
all of those being said i'll tell you
the the one that hurt the worst
was actually i was at dallas we're
playing detroit i caught a ball
i turned up and man i got hit right in
the freaking
thigh and uh he put his helmet right in
the middle of my thigh and i got one
you know i got a thigh bruise and a
charlie horse and it was one of those i
hit the ground and i remember i just
wanted to throw up
you know and i got up i got back
and uh i didn't come out i kept going
and
and luckily we were we were winning
pretty good and so about
call it you know eight minutes later i i
you know they
pulled the starters out of the game but
my gosh that thing
it hurt i thought every time i was gonna
run after that i was gonna throw up
because it it hurt that was one of the
worst ones as crazy as it is and that's
really not a big injury at all it's
nothing
but man it was painful and as a matter
of fact i got
you would be shocked how bad i got
messed with that so i had the normal
thigh pads right but after i got the
charlie horse
i'm not kidding you this thing was like
i was saying
my thigh pad looked like this that big
he was huge
so i started wearing these ginormous
my teammates would just mess with me all
the time like campbell's ipad oh my god
man
and uh they look like notebooks how was
the minute one of our teammates got a
freaking thigh bruise in a game i'd be
the first one over there how is parcells
to you
parcells is great man i i got the utmost
respect for parcells i love
parcells of death and here's why because
i always respected him
you know and i can tell you right now
there was plenty of times where i just
had it with him and you just there's
you just you want to let him have it
because you you can't stand the guy
anymore
but man he told you exactly where you
stood and he was a
master motivator he knew exactly how to
push your buttons and get the most out
of it but he also was 100 percent fair
with you he told you what was going on
if you wanted to know where you stood go
right to his office and he'll tell you
exactly where he stand now you better be
ready
because he's about to tell you the truth
you may hear something you don't want to
hear
uh but he was listen he was great and
for as hard as bill was and he was a
hard coach man
but yet god he had a great personality
and he just knew
how to uh he knew how to communicate to
everybody of all walks of life um
and he had a sense of humor you know he
did i i enjoyed my time with bill i
learned a lot of lessons under him
how many touchdown receptions do you
have 11 does that sound right
uh maybe somewhere in there i think just
to take over tens
i think in my career best one
your most memorable one yeah i actually
i know that one because that was 2005
i was at dallas we're playing kansas
city and
i've kind of told this story before this
was you know everybody knows bill it was
you know you you basically allow your
opponent to beat themselves you don't
beat yourself you don't turn the ball
over you find a way to run the ball
you know you you get inefficient uh
third downs because you're able to do
some things on first second down
um you know you get these fourth downs
you punt it you know you pin them play
good defense all those and i remember he
came in that week this is when they had
the number one offense in the league
they had priest holmes and
and those guys and uh he said listen
we're taking the cuffs off he actually
walked in the first thing he said was
defense we had a real good defense too
by the way
he's a defense you got your hands full
um and he said offense
you guys are going to have score 35 to
win this game i mean he just and that
was so
uncharacteristic of something that bill
would tell us but
long story short we got a shootout and
we were aggressive bill took the cuffs
off and sean
sean called a hell of a game sean payton
called a hell of a game and
you know and i can't tell the exact
score but it was in the 30s and
uh basically end of the game and uh
you know for the win we did a little pop
pass and it was on the goal line
and i just blocked the defensive end
slipped out and uh
you know bledsoe put it on me and we won
the game you know but it was kind of one
of those you remember it was just kind
of special
um because everything worked to a t as
to what coach said it would
and uh you know and look it's so easy
for me i mean look i
rarely go out on routes and so i'm
always blocking so all i got to do is
just block one more time or act like i
am then slip out nobody's going to cover
you so it was
the easiest thing ever but uh it was
pretty good
did you come up with the camo design for
the
detroit lions no actually this was this
is what they had last year this was
everything was what it was in your shirt
the shirt the same way the camera same
way this is the gear that they had here
last year and so
i like it though kind of feels like it
it matches me fits me a little bit
yeah i could see you in a you know
a duck bind or somebody you know
something like that do you got to dip in
right now
no you sure yeah i'm pretty sure
okay i just want to make sure maybe hold
on i can check
okay yeah i'm good yeah okay you're good
you look like you you'd have a dip
in well when when you've done things for
many years sometimes it looks like you
got it
uh coach good luck and uh good luck when
uh that blonde quarterback uh comes your
way
we're number 16 here uh officially in a
few weeks
i appreciate it thanks for having me on
thank you dan that's uh dan campbell
lions head coach